il y a quelque chose que j'aimerais te
montrer des temps d'attaque oui
je vais l'appeler blue back
les labres peuvent vivre jusqu'à 70 ans
ce sont des vieux sages
parce qu'une fois que les labres ont
trouvé leur endroit de prédilection
il ne le quitte plus
mais la seule façon de s'assurer qu'il
soit bien à l'abri cette n'en parler à
personne qu'est-ce qu'ils font l'eau
n'est pas c'est profonde à cet endroit
ils vont devoir creuser le récif
regarde-moi tous ces poissons certains
sont des espèces protégées comment ils
peuvent faire une chose pareille de nous
priver de notre avenir vous pensez
vraiment pouvoir empêcher ce projet
immobilier
vous voulez le tuer
et s'il ne revenait pas
si je devais ne plus jamais le revoir
[Musique]
bonjour je suis habite Jackson je vais
avoir 16 ans
et j'étudie la faune de cette baie
depuis l'âge de 8 ans
tout le récit va disparaître bah ça
c'est ce qu'on verra
la richesse incroyable de notre faune
aquatique
c'est un vrai donc une fellation
il a rien à craindre avec moi
[Musique]